kriminelle Straftäter Randalierer Klima
RF es wird viel gestritten und
geschimpft über die sogenannte letzte
Generation und ihre Aktionen andere
Leute wollen zur Arbeit fahren wegen
euch Penner komme ich jetzt zu spät ja
das sind ebenfalls schwere Straftaten
Straftatbestände gegen Leib und Leben
der Bevölkerung der normale Protest
funktioniert nicht wir müssen jetzt so
stören dass wir nicht ignoriert werden
können und das ist leider hier am besten
möglich Präventivhaft Verschärfung des
Strafrechts der Rechtsstaat soll er hat
durchgreifen heißt das aus der Politik
und tut das inzwischen auch mittlerweile
sogar mit Razzien und damit hat die
Diskussion eine neue Eskalationsstufe
erreicht ist das angemessen oder anders
gefragt was sind das für Leute die mit
Kartoffelbrei auf Bilder werfen und sich
auf Straßen kleben Aktivisten oder
Terroristen lass uns doch mal aufdröseln
herzlich willkommen bei einer neuen
Ausgabe von Inside Politik
[Applaus]
euch wird es wahrscheinlich genauso
gehen wie mir kaum ein Tag an dem ich
nicht irgendwo irgendwas über die
Aktionen der sogenannten letzten
Generationen oder von anderen Aktivisten
lese oder Hörer aber Moment da sind wir
nämlich schon mittendrin in der Debatte
sind das überhaupt Aktivisten hier schon
mal einer der nennt die ganz anders
warum sie das machen gerade
weißt du warum ich jetzt hier stehe weil
mein Sohn muss jetzt so okay und wegen
dir du steht mein Auto jetzt
noch dahin die feine englische Art ist
das zwar nicht aber der Mann muss mit
seinem kleinen Sohn dringend irgendwohin
ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht richtig
hören können wohin weil er so wütend war
da kann man seinen Ärger schon verstehen
oder der Ärger der sogenannten letzten
Generation ist aber auch groß darüber
dass die Politik zu wenig tot Klimaziele
verfehlt Klimakonferenzen wie zuletzt
die in Sharm el Sheikh nur mit
kleinstmöglichen Kompromissen im Moment
diese Form des Protestes das effektivste
Mittel was uns am Ende noch übrig bleibt
weil keine anderen Protestformen mehr
ausreichen und wir haben nicht mehr viel
Zeit wir rasen auf eine Klimakatastrophe
zu wir sind jetzt schon mittendrin und
wir müssen jetzt handeln fehlärger also
auf beiden Seiten Deutschland diskutiert
seit Monaten heftig schauen wir uns die
Konfrontation von Politik und letzter
Generation etwas genauer an ein paar
krasse Aktion und Momente habt ihr
eventuell schon wieder vergessen so ging
es mir jedenfalls
[Musik]
wisst ihr noch der Hungerstreik vom
Kanzleramt mit zwei der streiken dann
hat sich Olaf Scholz Ende 2021 getroffen
ja ein paar Bilder ich weiß nicht wie es
euch geht aber für mich zumindest war
das der erste Moment in dem ich so
richtig bewusst von der sogenannten
letzten Generation gehört habe und von
ihrer radikaleren Form des klimaprotests
und nicht nur ich das wochenlange
hungern hat so viel Aufsehen erregt dass
der Kanzler irgendwann gar nicht mehr
anders konnte als ich mit den Leuten zu
treffen auch weil Scholz und seine Ampel
da wirklich gerade ganz frisch im Amt
und angetreten waren mit dem Versprechen
vieles anders also besser zu machen als
zum Beispiel die groko die ein
klimagesetz beschlossen hatte das vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Teilen als
verfassungswidrig erklärt worden war was
ein ganz schöner Hammer war groko und
Klimaschutz das lief also nicht so gut
groko und Klimaschützer auch nicht
schauen wir mal kurz auf den damaligen
Wirtschaft und Energieminister Peter
Altmaier auf einer Demo von Fridays for
future 2019 schon der Kontakt mit der
Jugendbewegung Fridays for future fällt
der Union ziemlich schwer
[Applaus]
mit der Ampel sollte das alles anders
also besser laufen also traf Sie Scholz
mit der letzten Generation und die
kündigte auf genau diesem Treffen exakt
das an was seit Anfang 2022 läuft
großflächiger und aufsehenerregende
Aktionen Kartoffelbrei auf ein Gemälde
von Manet zum Beispiel das das muss man
ja immer dazu sagen geschützt war durch
eine Glasscheibe er war die Aufregung
vielleicht doch ein bisschen übertrieben
den Bildern ist ja zum Glück nichts
passiert dann gibt es aber ja auch noch
die Straßenblockaden und da sieht das
dann anders aus das Fest eben auf
Kreuzungen auf Autobahnauffahrten so
dass Autos nicht weiterfahren können das
macht viele sehr sehr sauer wegen dir du
steht mein Auto jetzt noch
dahin genauso die Blockade von Flughäfen
denn solche Aktionen sind sehr riskant
bis gefährlich Anfang November dann
starb eine Radfahrerin hier in Berlin
und es gab einen Zusammenhang mit den
sogenannten Klima Klebern eine
44-jährige Frau war von einem
Betonmischer überfahren worden ein
Spezialfahrzeug dass sie unter dem LKW
befreien sollte brauchte sehr lange bis
es sich den Weg zur Unfallstelle gebahnt
hatte zeitgleich stattfindende
Feuerwehr aber erschwerten die
klimakleber die Rettung erheblich jetzt
ermittelt die Staatsanwaltschaft und das
kann wohl noch sehr lange dauern klar
ist aber seitdem läuft die Debatte
erbitterter denn je Stichwort volle
Härte des Rechtsstaats
[Musik]
lass mich mal so anfangen generell
klatschen die allerwenigsten der im
Bundestag vertretenden Parteien dem
Blockierern Beifall sPD FDP ja sogar die
Grünen also die klimaschutzpartei gehen
auf Distanz ein Ratschlag an diese
jungen Menschen bringt eure Energie ein
dass ihr helft dass wir mehr Klimaschutz
durchsetzen helft nicht den Gegner des
Klimaschutzes diese Maßnahmen sind
Wasser auf die Mühlen von denjenigen die
gegen Klimaschutz sind ich glaube die
Leute die da im Stau stehen verstehen
nicht plötzlich die Ernsthaftigkeit des
anliegen sondern ärgern sich nur von
vorne bis hinten und deshalb glaube ich
ist das kein guter Anfall aber auch er
lässt Wissen eindringen auf das Rollfeld
eines Flughafens kann wegen eines
gefährlichen Eingriffs in den
Luftverkehr strafbar sein im Grundsatz
also Einigkeit in der Radikalität der
Ablehnung aber gibt es große
Unterschiede am weitesten geht dabei
nicht allzu überraschen die AFD die AFD
ist ja bekannt für krasse Politik
gemäßigter aber Schaf mit ihrer Position
CDU und CSU schwere Straftaten
es braucht deutlich härtere Strafen für
klimakaoten um einer weiteren
Radikalisierung in Teilen dieser
Klimabewegung entgegenzuwirken und
Nachahmer abzuschrecken die Entstehung
einer Klima RAF muss verhindert werden
hat Alexander Dobrind recht sind die
klimakleber Terroristen also
Staatsfeinde quasi Reichsbürger in Grün
das habe ich sarattacke gefragt
Rechtsexpertin bei uns im ZDF Menschen
die sich aus Protest auf die Straße
kleben sind ganz klar keine Terroristen
denn ein Terrorist ist in Deutschland
per Gesetz jemand der bereit ist zu
Morden zu töten schwere Straftaten zu
begehen um die Demokratie anzugreifen um
unsere Gesellschaft zu destabilisieren
Klima Kleber sind zwar im Zweifel auch
bereit eine Straftat zu Beginn eine
Nötigung und wollen auch politischen
Druck aufbauen sind aber Meilen weiter
von entfernt zu morden um unsere
Demokratie anzugreifen und deshalb ganz
klar keine Terroristen okay die
Bezeichnung als Terroristen gehört also
eher wohl in die Kategorie politische
Polemik aber lass uns Begrifflichkeiten
mal beiseite lassen wie seht ihr das ist
das krimineller Protest oder wird der
protestkriminalisiert schreibt eure
Meinung gerne in die Kommentare
diskutiert miteinander und auch mit uns
zurück zum Thema ob nun Terrorismus oder
nicht die Rufe nach härteren Strafen
werden lauter und die Suche nach
Strategien die Aktionen möglichst zu
verhindern kreativer auch da werfen wir
mal einen Blick drauf
[Musik]
die Unionsparteien machen Nägel mit
Köpfen und haben im November diesen
Gesetzentwurf hier vorgelegt Titel
Straßen Blockierer und
museumsrandalierer Hertha bestrafen
Menschen und Kulturgüter vor radikalen
Protest schützen unter anderem steht
darin dass Straßenblockaden künftig mit
bis zu fünf Jahren Haft bestraft werden
können sollen der Antrag ist nicht
durchgekommen aber dann passierte das am
24 November wurde der Berliner Flughafen
blockiert und da reichte es sowohl der
bundesinnenministerin als auch dem
Bundesjustizminister endgültig das ist
keine Form von legitimen Protest ich
will das eindeutig sagen ist ein
gefährlicher Eingriff in den Flugverkehr
gefährdet Menschen und deswegen ist es
auch nicht in Ordnung und muss in einem
Rechtsstaat dann auch bestraft werden
aber nicht nur der Bund auch die Länder
werden tätig Bayern greift hier als
erstes Bundesland direkt knallhart durch
mit der vollhärte des Gesetzes spätleute
präventiv für 30 Tage ein und verbietet
Straßenblockaden in München jetzt
erstmal generell falls sie nicht 48
Stunden angekündigt werden womit sie ja
de facto relativ einfach verhindert
werden können typisch Bayern in der
corona-hochzeit zog Ministerpräsident
Markus Söder auch so ziemlich alle
Register und verhängte sogar
Ausgangssperren die hat ein Gericht
inzwischen aber für nicht rechtmäßig
erklärt man muss also mal abwarten ob er
mit seinem Umgang mit den
klimaprotestern durchkommt Präventivhaft
ist ein weiteres Mittel zu dem mehrere
Länder greifen werden Straftaten
angekündigt können Leute also
vorsorglich verhaftet werden am
schärfsten geht da Überraschung Bayern
vor bis zu 30 Tage lang können dort
Aktivisten hinter Gitter kommen eine
Regelung die wohl vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht landen wird und
mit überschaubarem
abschreckungspotenzial ich weiß dass mir
das erneut droht
wenn ich wieder in München auf die
Straße gehe
doch wir werden uns nicht von
Gefängnisstrafen abhalten für eine gute
Zukunft zu kämpfen vor ein paar Tagen
dann eine neue Eskalationsstufe Razzien
in 11 Bundesländern wurden die Wohnungen
von Aktivisten oder Terroristen
durchsucht es bestehe der Verdacht dass
die letzte Generation von einer klaren
Rollenverteilung und einer
kontinuierlichen Struktur geprägt sei
sagte die Staatsanwaltschaft in
Neuruppin und dass der Zweck der
Gruppierung zumindest auch auf die
Begehung von Straftaten hinreichenden
Gewichts ausgerichtet sein Verdacht das
ist wichtig erwiesen ist das noch nicht
Grund für diese Razzia für die
Wohnungsdurchsuchung sind gerade nicht
nur die klimakleber Aktion sondern der
Vorwurf Störung einer Ölraffinerie und
Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung in
diesem Zusammenhang können
Durchsuchungen verhältnismäßig sein wenn
es keinen milderes Mittel gab und sich
die Ermittler wirklich Erkenntnisse
davon versprechen aber gerade nicht als
Schikane denn der Schutz der Wohnung ist
ein extrem hohes Gut im Grundgesetz
garantiert und darf nicht einfach so
angegriffen werden
[Musik]
die klimafreunde als Staatsfeinde
hinzustellen obwohl sie ja gerade auf
die Einhaltung politischer versprechen
brauchen das funktioniert nicht so ganz
stand jetzt aber es gibt fernab der
Frage wie Ungehorsam ziviler Ungehorsam
sein darf oder sogar muss ja eine
ebenfalls sehr wichtige Frage wie sehr
dienen diese Aktionen eigentlich dem
Klima Umfragen zeigen nicht wirklich die
Leute sind von den Aktionen genauso
genervt wie die Politik zeigt zum
Beispiel eine Umfrage von RTL NTV Anfang
Dezember da sagen 82% der Befragten dass
sie kein Verständnis dafür haben das ist
schon sehr eindeutig dazu passt dieser
Polizist ich sage Ihnen ich spreche mit
vielen Leuten tagtäglich die schaffen
keine Akzeptanz dadurch im Gegenteil sie
machen die Leute wütend die Aktionen
werden also weitergehen die Debatte wird
auch weitergehen wir freuen uns wenn ihr
euch an ihr beteiligt und wenn euch
dieser Ausgabe von inside-politiks
gefallen hat und ihr unter dem Video den
Daumen hebt und uns vielleicht sogar
abonniert und auf das nächste Mal freuen
wir uns auch bis dann